una crisis brutal en mi amar de esta
manera folker turk se refirió a la
situación política que atraviesa la
nación asiática desde el golpe de estado
de 2021 turk abordó los reportes que
señalan a la junta militar birmana de
violaciones masivas a los Derechos
Humanos dentro del territorio
específicamente contra La minoría
musulmana rojinya el alto comisionado de
Naciones Unidas para los Derechos
Humanos pidió a los miembros del
organismo buscaron una solución efectiva
para la crisis
las condiciones necesarias para el
retorno voluntario seguro y digno de los
refugiados también mar Simplemente no
existen los más de un millón de
roshinchas que permanecen en el exilio
en bangladesh y otros países así como
los cientos de miles que son desplazados
internos se enfrentan a un presente
sombrío y a un futuro peor
una de las poblaciones apatridas más
grandes del mundo la ley de ciudadanía
puesta en 1982 no reconoce a los
miembros de la comunidad como ciudadanos
de myanmar dando pie a décadas de
persecución y opresión al pueblo rojinya
El golpe de estado de 2021 intensificó
El Éxodo bangladesh ha sido el destino
para más de un millón de rojillas Sin
embargo no se han encontrado con el
mejor futuro que buscaban dejamos
nuestro hogar en myanmar Y vinimos aquí
a vivir como refugiados bajo un enorme
presión solo porque no podíamos soportar
la opresión Sí aquí también tenemos que
sufrir un plato similar será una gran
pérdida para la comunidad el 5 de marzo
un incendio destrozó un campo de
refugiados rojinya en el distrito de Cox
bazar al sureste de bangladesh aunque no
se reportaron muertos las más de 12.000
personas que vivían ahí quedaron sin
hogar